every day of these three years as a
developer
i said to myself this this is not me
this is not me by the way i knew it also
during my studies okay i wasn't the best
student
in as an engineer and definitely not as
a developer
and eventually i said i i'm a people
person
i want to go out and meet people in my
job
in my day-to-day job i don't want to
spend my time
debugging it doesn't bring my my full
you know self-expression welcome to
20-minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford bitcoin and fintech
meet sagi bakshi the ceo of coin mama
sagi is a computer science engineer with
over 20 years of experience in the tech
industry
and an extensive background in
telecommunications ad tech and
blockchain
technologies he joins coin mama from
tech unicorn iron source
which recently announced their ipo
intention with an estimated valuation of
six to eight billion dollars
where he was a member of the founding
team and from 2011 to 2018
served as general manager of the
company's biggest division
sagi bakshi thank you for joining me on
20 minute leaders good morning
good morning good morning thank you very
much
i see the beautiful skyline uh behind
you
eh where are you right now
of course sagi your journey is a
remarkable it's it's
fascinating and the reason why i'm i'm
excited is because you know
on the out from the outside looking into
your journey you're like yes of course
he
it makes perfect sense what he did but
you know just before we started
recording this you mentioned that you
know one of the one of the themes that
you're
looking back on your journey is that you
know sometimes you realize that you were
doing things that you
weren't meant to be doing and you
weren't really enjoying or weren't good
fit for so i'm excited to talk about
those things and talk about your
insights from your journey
as well as bitcoin the the crypto
revolution and
and of course coin mama so saggy take me
all the way back as far as you want
who is segee bakshi and walk me a little
bit through your journey
okay i know a lot of people a lot of
youngsters you know you finish high
school you don't know what you want to
do
you don't know what you want to do when
you grow up and
the first junction of a the first big
decision you need to take is
what the what kind of what major you're
doing in college in university
i didn't really know what i want to do
so i went
to something that looks very lucrative
very
wanted at that time it was 1998
and the telecom and the high-tech
boom was was right like what we see now
in in
crypto almost the same so i went to
study
in communication consist
communication systems engineering okay
and my first job was as a developer as
an engineer
in a startup that was acquired by cisco
systems
now i spent there three years in which
every day of these three years as a
developer
i said to myself this this is not me
this is not me by the way i knew it also
during my studies okay i wasn't the best
student
in as an engineer and definitely not as
a developer
and eventually i said i i'm a people
person
i want to go out and meet people in my
job
in my day-to-day job i don't want to
spend my time
debugging i wasn't good
at it and i knew that it doesn't bring
my my
full you know self-expression
my next job was a pre-sale engineer
pre-sale it means you go out um
together with a sales person and you
communicate with engineers on the other
side of the customer and you build
network architecture for internet
service providers for example
and i we were selling telecom equipment
to to the biggest
telecom providers at that period i
traveled a lot
so i think it was amazing for
for you know for 27 28 year old
to travel and and explore different
cultures
and different management systems
of how to manage and i encounter how the
chinese are doing it how the europeans
are doing it how
the united states is doing it and how
latin america is doing everyone is doing
it differently
and it depends if you are a small
startup or or a big corporate
no sake i do have to ask a question that
i think is
hugely relevant to so many people that i
know
and this idea of you know being in a
place where
you know the norm is saying one thing
you're
rationalizing a certain journey
for a career trajectory like you know
being an engineer being a developer
for three years you realize that this is
probably not the best place for you
and what i'm curious about is both why
is it
three years instead of you know half a
year and you know
higher slow fire fast also yourself and
the other question is how do you even
get the courage to go and do that
because most people that i know wouldn't
even
wouldn't even be able to leave after
three years they would just do it for
life
yeah if you work in cisco you don't live
you have to be crazy to leave cisco
cisco used to be
the best employer in the world
people and you know my friends thought
that i'm crazy
i i left to a small startup
and and i actually i mean i was young
i'm an adventurer okay an adventurous
person i think
i i said this is the time to take risks
and and obviously it wasn't
that a big of a risk because i stayed in
telecom industry
i stayed as an engineer doing something
a bit different so it
wouldn't say that was the the big
leap of faith but later on a friend a
childhood friend of mine called me and
said look
i'm setting up a bootstrap and i want
you to join
it's going to be cool startup around the
internet
and i said i don't know i don't know
i have a a good career
path in front of me i'm in the telecom
industry
i'm an engineer i'm not sure about the
internet i'm not sure about
ad ethic you know it was around edtech
eventually i joined after you know a few
months that he that he kept calling me
and
later on that company is known today as
iron source
one of the biggest biggest biggest
unicorns in israel
we're going i'm going to do an ipo very
soon
it's a it's your success story i've been
there eight years
and i was so lucky to be part of that
journey
as the first employee of that company
and then unbelievable
actually to lead people and to manage
and i managed their
a division of 200 employees it was
amazing
and and that was the moment where i said
this is my self-expression okay
this is my zone this is what i like to
do
to lead people around technology so my
technological background
really really helped me to lead that
kind of
of a startup but i have to hear a little
bit about that
first employee experience a little bit
because
you know very few people get to be first
employees at a startup let alone a
startup that
is a an israeli unicorn that is going to
ipo so
you know looking back what what are some
of you know the
the crazy experiences of of a first
employee are you
you know do you realize you're part of
this rocket ship do you
do you join in on the founders on their
journey like what is the sort of like
relationship
you have with this rocket ship that's
going
yeah so at first i mean there was a
feeling that this is going to be big
there was a feeling
in the early days as well we were kind
of a hyped and everyone in tel aviv was
talking about us
so it was fun but you know we needed to
organize a company we needed to build
infrastructure to grow
we were five people four founders and
one employee
and then we realized okay this employee
myself
he needs a paycheck how do we issue a
paycheck we need to establish
the camp the company we need to register
the company
so wow and then i said okay i don't have
a contract
let's find a template for a con for
hiring
a new employees so i went to the
internet and find a template for a
contractor we did everything we have
ourselves obviously
and then the privilege of building a
company
is like everything you learned up until
that moment
you put it and you design it as you wish
as you think a company should be
and and it's a great privilege i mean
it's a it's a joyful
journey you recruit the people you want
you that you believe
i mean it's it's great to be the boss
eventually you do a lot of mistakes as a
startup you never did it before
you you do a lot of mistakes along the
way
but i think the team there was super
super strong
and up until today i mean they have a
lot of amazing founders
they are like i think 10 different
founders
join together as a group each one of
them is like
you know the h1 has a different
superpower and and
the ceo there is amazing what did you
learn mo
from watching the company and being a
part of that growth all the way up to
managing
you said 200 people you're going from
being a single employee to now
being a general manager of the largest
division and managing 200 people
what did you have to learn along the way
that looking back you're like wow like
that's really really cool
it's all about the people i mean it's
it's a very
well-known phrase but it's actually you
learn it
in the hard way it's all about the
people if you recruit
carefully hire slowly
and you do not compromise on the quality
of the people that you
on board to your team you are doing
something good
you can wait i don't know six months 12
months
to man a position and and you don't
compromise
every wrong decision in hiring will cost
the company
a lot of money and time and it will
reflect poorly
on the other team members so right
hiring is one of the most important jobs
of the
ceo the ceo needs to be part of hiring
process
obviously you cannot do it a in a
in an 800 employees in 800
employees a company but up until the
moment that you can
you should interview and should be part
of the hiring process
amazing so segee now you've moved a
little bit from ad tech
you're entering the the crazy world of
of crypto and cryptocurrencies and
and i'd love to to first understand a
little bit better the
the the bitcoin revolution the
cryptocurrency revolution
what where are we in 2021 we've been
hearing about this for a while
i've been you know seeing my friends
almost having heart attacks every day
that they're watching
uh their their you know fraction of a
bitcoin go up and down dramatically
and and today you're also the ceo of
coin mama and i'd love to hear a little
bit about what that's about so
so segi please you know help me
understand a little bit better what's
happening with our world today
okay so bitcoin uh
was established like it was a test it
was a
an experiment of a cryptographer
an anonymous crypto cryptographer called
satoshi nakamoto
he issued the white paper and that
brilliant
nine pages white paper is about to
change the world
okay it's about to change everything in
our
way of how do we transfer value to each
other
and how do we interact and he actually
solved a very very difficult and
hundreds of years of of a of his problem
algorithmic problem
uh to how to create trust between
several parties that
do not trust each other i mean in order
to
transfer money or value from me to you
we need to trust someone so up until
today we trusted a third party called
a bank or if you do it on a venmo
or something like that you trust demo
which trusts the bank
a lot of entities involved in this
process satoshi actually created the
first
chain the first network that people can
store value and transfer value to each
other
solely depending on algorithms okay and
that these are
transparent algorithms everyone knows
what is going on
on the blockchain everyone can
understand
so we totally believe that this
technology is about to change the world
i don't think we'd
experience it yet okay
everyone is talking about bitcoin some
people are doubling
with the idea of buying a little bit
but we it didn't start yet
okay it's it's a it's a technology shift
it's a mindset
shift people trust uh today they think
they trust
their governments their banks
but it will take time for them to
understand that there is a new
way to store value so it's i think it's
the first time in history that you can
actually own something
without having to protect it with guns
or with big fences okay right
you can store your entire family with
in your head by memorizing 12
words of the seed phrase okay
and you can carry your family with your
generation with
in your head traveling around the world
memorizing 12 words that's
it and then you can pass borders and
then you can escape
any tyranny any dictatorships
any checkpoints in borders if you're a
refugee
you can send money to your families uh
you know in in remittance
transactions that today cost 10
or 11 when when you are a philippine
employee wants to send
a money back to your family so many use
cases and
and bitcoin is is totally aligned with
the human rights
movement that will allow more freedom
and more
more self-sovereignity to to
to the unbanked people there are around
2 billion
people around the world that don't have
any access to bank services
wow all you need is all you need is a
smartphone and it's probably going to be
much faster for them to get an internet
connection than for them to have another
branch
of their local bank coming to their to
their rural
area right
yeah for example in africa with i mean
there's the whole notion of
skipping the the laptop okay laptop is
too expensive
no one and people in africa don't have
enough money to buy a laptop
but so they skipped it and they own
feature phones and smartphones
and that's their connectivity to the
internet and obviously they need to
improve the infrastructure of the
internet there but we're already seeing
an increase of usage of
cryptocurrency in africa so
the vision of coin mama that's why i
joined coin mama
even though i had an amazing job an
amazing challenge amazing team at iron
source
this is what motivates me okay this is
my passion
it's like the real vision of what is
going to happen in the next
10 to 20 years in this field of
currencies of how to create value
how to move value and how to store value
using cryptography
and and computer science only okay
so that's why i joined coin mama as the
ceo like a year and a half ago
and it's an online company okay we sell
bitcoin to 190 countries in the world
it's a growing startup and and we
are so happy and and we are so lucky to
do what we do we come
every morning with joy with a smile
and you say how lucky we are to
to participate in this revolution
a coin mama today is it has 60 employees
in two countries in our in ireland we
have a
an office in ireland a daughter company
there with six employees
and the majority is here in israel in
tel aviv
a lot of r d a lot of data science
a lot of analysts um
we are selling bitcoin we are not an
exchange okay
it's just an otc and over the counter it
means
when you come and register and upload
your uh
documentation and we approve you you can
buy bitcoin from us
you just upload some payment method i
will pay with
apple pay or or you just a credit card
or bank wire
and you get the bitcoin from us so we
are a counterparty to this
transaction you have to bring your own
wallet you have to know what you do
we encourage everyone do not buy
if you don't know what you are buying
learn
what is bitcoin first go online
take some time takes a few take a few
days
consult your friends understand exactly
what is bitcoin otherwise
if you buy in order to get rich fast you
will that's the fastest way to get there
to be poor okay you're going to lose
everything
if you're don't know what you're buying
it's a risky asset
yes it's it's very young that's why it's
so volatile
but you need strong conviction you need
to understand what you're doing in order
to be able to hold
totally right and to overcome this
crazy volatility so what i'm hearing
from you segi is that on one hand you're
saying
listen i have no doubt that the future
is going to be different for us all it's
going to have
this decentralized trust mechanism where
all you really need in order to manage
your wealth is this
seed of 12 words that you memorized
on the other hand you know we're today
in 2021
we're just seeing this rise we're
talking about a huge consumer shift and
whoever wants to
be part of this and ride that first wave
need to have you know to take some
responsibility with you know managing
the the volatility of that first wave
but in the long run
it doesn't sound like you have many you
know
you're not you don't think that there is
a chance even that
this is not going to take the world by
storm that's what i'm gathering from
from what you're saying right
not the chance not a chance now
obviously in 1995
or 1996 like after jeff bezos
said i'm going to sell books online
right
so people said are you who is going to
put
credit card details online on the
internet
are you crazy and he said yes yes they
are going to put some credit card
details
and they will buy books from me
eventually
he said no people will buy not only
books
they will buy the internet is going to
be huge and it will serve us
in in many different areas of our life
and that was 1997 1998 and
that's when you need true vision for 20.
so this is where we are today 25 years
after
the first idea more or less of jeff
bezos and
and only if you stick to the vision if
you true a true believer
you can make this kind of a revolution
and and and the world
needs this revolution the world needs a
better
a stable a better way to transfer value
we cannot trust our government currency
i i can say that in our in my own
country i can
understand people in the united states
are saying it i can understand people in
the european union saying it
every government it tends to fail
uh their economy every tens a few tens
of months right
right you don't need an internet account
the one thing that i'm leaving here with
certainty is that i need to go do a lot
more research because i think that i
i i you know i i undervalued and i think
that a lot of the people that i
talked to i was wealthy you know we look
at bitcoin as this
interesting asset to to trade with today
but what you're referring to is just a a
much much bigger consumer shift
in in you know in in communities that i
wasn't even thinking of i wasn't even
thinking about of how
you know this decentralized system is
going to impact the two billion people
that aren't connected to
the financial grid today and you're
looking at
and you know i can definitely start you
know seeing the seeds of how this is
completely going to revolutionize
you know every industry knowledge this
not just the financial so thank you for
opening my mind to that and
and i have my homework cut out for me
before we leave sega i have to ask the
most important question
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself
okay so i'm a social animal
i i am adventurous
and i'm a dad i love that i think that's
thank you very very much best of luck
with coin mama thank you for sharing
with me your journey all the way from
from you know being an engineer
realizing that you're probably not go
not trying or not going to be the best
engineer in the room nevertheless going
to become the first employee of iron
source one of the israel's biggest
prides to
now joining coin mama and being a part
of what
seems to be an inevitable and awesome
revolution
so thank you for the positive impact
you're making and thank you for spending
your time with me here
sure thanks a lot take care thank you
you